Before we jump into the engine, one last thing I wanted to touch on before you
start putting work into you know setting up all the blueprints is just
making sure that you have a strong foundation to your skeletal mesh so
that everything you're doing in engine goes much more smoothly. Now
there are some things that you need to think about before importing
your vehicle. So spend some time just considering how your vehicle is going
to move and about the hierarchy of bones that you need to create for your
skeleton. So for example if you have a suspension system, consider how those
different parts will be moving, where the pivots should be, what directions the
bones should be oriented, just to help out with any of the blueprinting work
or control rig work later down the pipeline. But for the absolute basics
for the system to work, here are some useful tips that will mean you're not
fighting any of the default settings and your initial setup should be a lot
easier basically. So your vehicle should be facing down the positive x-axis.
So whichever way you want your vehicle to be facing when they're driving, make
sure that that's down the positive x-axis. Something that helps for use in
the wheel blueprint later on would be to measure the radius of your wheels
because that's that's just some information that the wheel blueprint
needs. When it comes to your joints and your skeleton, now it can be as
complicated as you like or as simple as you like, but when it comes to a
four-wheeled vehicle which is what we'll be setting up today, it needs a
minimum of five bones in the skeleton and this would be one for the root and
then four for the wheels, so one for each wheel. And when you're placing and
orienting your joints, this is specifically for the the wheel and the
route, make sure that they are x-forward and z-up and this will
basically ensure that they roll on the y-axis and steer on the z-axis.
And your wheel joints should be placed at the center of your wheel mesh so
that they rotate properly when rolling and your wheel meshes should also be
weighted to just one joint only so that there's no influence from other bones
in the skeleton, otherwise you're gonna get some real funky results. And as
long as you stick to these basics and you get these ones correct, the rest
of the setup in engine should be a lot more straightforward.